the most important walls in western
history
aren't even in the west they surround
the modern city of istanbul
constantinople as the romans called it
and for a thousand years
the fate of europe depended on them
constantinople was designed to be the
center of the world
when the frontiers of the roman empire
began to crumble in the 4th century
the capital was moved to the cultured
wealthy and still stable east
there at the crossroads between europe
and asia the hub of the major trade
routes of the ancient world
the emperor constantine built his city
this was the city of libraries and
universities
20 times the size of london or paris at
the time
it contained the priceless knowledge of
the classical world which was fading in
the west
to protect this masterpiece from its
many enemies constantine's successors
built the finest defensive
fortifications ever made
the first line of protection was a moat
60 feet wide and 22 feet deep
stretching all four miles from coast to
coast
pipes from inside the city could fill it
at the first sight of the enemy
and a short wall protected archers who
could fire at the soaked soldiers trying
to swim across those who were lucky
enough to clear the moat
had to contend with an unceasing barrage
from the 27-foot outer wall above
arrows spears or far worse greek fire
an ancient form of napalm that would
ignite on contact
and couldn't be extinguished by water
would rain down on them
squads of roman defenders would carry
portable flamethrowers
spraying anyone trying to climb out of
the moat the terrified victims would
leap back only to find that they still
burned underwater
at times the romans would also mount
siphons onto the ramparts
and launch clay pots full of greek fire
from catapults at an invading army
the front lines would turn into an
inferno making it appear as if the earth
itself was on fire
if by some miracle the outer wall was
compromised
attackers would be faced with the final
defense the great inner wall
these walls were wide enough to have
four men ride side by side
allowing troops to be rushed wherever
they were needed
attila the hun destroyer of
civilizations who named himself the
scourge of god
took one look at them and turned around
the avars battled the walls uselessly
till their catapults ran out of rocks
the turks tried to tunnel under them but
found the foundations too
solid the arabs tried to starve the city
into submission
but ran out of food themselves and had
to resort to cannibalism
it took the guns of the modern world to
finally bring them down
in 1453 the turks brought their
superweapon
a monster cannon that could fire a
fifteen hundred pound stone ball over a
mile
together with more than a hundred
smaller guns they kept up a steady
bombardment day and night
a section of the old walls collapsed but
even in their death throws they proved
formidable
the rubble absorbed the shock of the
cannonballs better than the solid wall
it took a month and a half of continuous
blasting to finally open a breach
the last roman emperor constantine xi
drew his sword
and jumped into the gap to stop the
onrushing horde disappearing
into legend the city was taken
and the roman empire finally disappeared
but those broken walls had one last gift
as the survivors fled the doomed city
they brought with them their precious
books and their ancient traditions
they traveled west to italy reintroduced
the greek language and learning to
western europe
and ignited the renaissance thanks to
constance nopel's walls
that pile of brick and marble that
guarded them for so long
we still have our classical past
you